all right so Star Trek Picard season
three
it's good to the Odyssey of Star Trek
Picard has been a wild one I saw season
one I I felt I was nice to season one in
season two I started watching it after
the whole thing had come out so I
already heard the chatter that people
didn't like it that chatter mixed with
what I was seeing in season two I got to
about episode two and I was like I'm
good gotta admit though I did laugh when
Picard looks right at Q and he was like
I'm too old for your [__] so I
wasn't interested in season three and
then people started saying it was good
I'm talking
silver-haired old school Star Trek fans
were saying no it's really good so I
binged it
yeah it's really good also this is gonna
be generally speaking a spoiler-free
video I know some people might want me
to delve deeper into the goings-on of
season three of Picard but
that's a balancing act right there but
there are reveals moments plot lines
unfolding in which I think it'll serve
you best watching it unfold not knowing
it's coming rather than me telling you
it's coming and it's just the impact's
not as great I am going to talk about
Beverly crusher's son
and that Maury Povich kind of way who is
the father I am going to talk about the
lineage because I feel like that's
important to talk about when talking
about this season pretty sure you find
out in episode two so it's fine now the
big question is do you need to watch
seasons one and two to understand what's
going on in season three no you don't
they make some references to season one
don't know if they may need to season
two but I guess that speaks to the fact
that you don't need to watch season two
because I didn't feel like I was missing
anything but yeah essentially Picard's
season three could have been called Star
Trek Picard no seriously we mean it this
time the character Rafi is the only
character in season three that I
recognize from season one at I was like
everyone else is just gone so if you
haven't seen it you might be like who
who is this person who's this character
why do I care but pretty soon it's going
to be this character is hanging out with
Wharf so if you don't know who she is at
least she's hanging out with Worf you
know Wharf you know what really hit me
after episode one when the end credit
song was the musical score to Star Trek
first Contact which is what one of the
most beautiful Star Trek songs ever made
that's when I was like okay in terms of
song Choice it's a pretty good pull
right there it's they seem to know what
the fans want I'll keep going it's
amazing what music can do and I just
fell in love with that theme in the
movie theaters when I saw first Contact
it was incredible and I have to talk
about Jack Crusher because family is a
huge part of the theme of Picard's
season three feels weird to even call it
Picard season three I might actually
call it Picard yes we mean it we're
serious this time not just the theme of
The Blood Ties of family but also the
family that you adopt throughout life I
mean the Enterprise the crew is a family
they talk about that in hearing you
absolutely feel it there's this one
scene where seven of nines reminiscing
about Voyager and again with the
importance of musical cues you hear the
voyager's theme start to swell in the
background almost like this is
yeah business hitting there's another
thing I liked about this this isn't just
a love letter to Next Generation I mean
it is but it's a love letter to that
chapter in the federation's Life in that
time frame you had Next Generation Deep
Space Nine and Voyager and you get ties
to all of it at some point it actually
felt very MKX like if I look back at
Mortal Kombat X I feel Mortal Kombat X
did a really good job at having the
Legacy characters age and then they
bring their offspring their sons and
daughters and their friends into it it
all mixed really well that's what this
feels like you know Jordi laforge has a
daughter she's at the helm Picard and
Beverly Crusher have their son jack yeah
oopsie Daisy I'm editing this video and
I realize I forgot to tell you jack is
the love child of Beverly Crusher and
Jean Louis Picard okay moving on I know
this may finish me shut up Wesley and
there's Intrigue there's mystery with
Jack you're like why is he why does he
seem to see the upside down from
stranger things what's going on with him
I mean yeah granted it still deals with
the whole uh Luke you never really
wanted a son he didn't think you'd be
good at it I'm like
so Inner Light still didn't happen and
okay whatever but if you're going to
ignore inner light at least give me a
compelling character dynamic between
these two and I felt they did now
bringing the characters back I was
worried about wharfs probably another
reason I was like I don't need to watch
this because in the trailer and also in
the show warp says something about it
you should know that I now prefer
pacifism to a combat we're all gonna die
I was like of course they took the proud
warrior Klingon and they're making him a
pacifist what there's nothing more 2023
than that but it's not really like that
the first thing he does is kill a group
of scumbags decapitates this one dude I
was like oh okay so you're still proud
Klingon Warrior Wharf you just you know
you meditate and find your center before
or after doing that I can get behind
that that's awesome we do have some
newcomers as well the villains played by
Amanda Plummer she plays vatic Amanda
Plummer is such an interesting choice
because I'm used to her playing quirky
characters and she absolutely doesn't
hear her on the edge of Madness is
absolutely in line with the character
and I dug what her character was tied
into damn spoiler free
I
I like that that was a good pull and I
got to give props to Brent Spiner my
recent binge of Star Trek the Next
Generation I'd watch all the special
features at the end of each of the
seasons and they all just give so much
love to Brent Spiner like Patrick
Stewart's like he is so talented and you
really do see it you look at that
episode
um
Fistful of dadas is what it's called
where he the the Holodeck starts going
awry so data is playing like Brent
Spiner anyway is playing all the
characters you just see the range there
prefacing that leading into the point
here which is when he's data and he
would snap to lore and he'd snapped a b
forward he has to play all these
characters it reminded me of Willem
Dafoe and Spider-Man when he's Norman
Osborne and the Green Goblin talking to
himself in the mirror and that's so
great to see because you know you grow
up loving this crew of characters and
when they're all coming back
you hope they haven't lost it you just
hope it feels as seamless as it feels in
your head it all worked and they all
still got it they feel like they're
characters you know you were never like
that doesn't feel like Jordy laforge
because it totally feels like Jordy
laforge Riker feels like Riker War feels
like Wharf and data has now come closer
than ever to his actual ultimate goal
his goal isn't just to get emotion it's
like he got emotion everyone was like
that's good enough there's a respect to
the characters shown here in a world
where Life Is Life and sometimes friends
drift apart you get the feeling yeah
this crew hasn't seen each other in a
very long time
but they come back together
well because time is relative it could
be a million years but they are still
that family I will say there were a
couple moments where I was like that is
Nostalgia bait you know like Moriarty
saw him in the trailer and I was like oh
[__] Moriarty's coming back so we didn't
that little simulation he was in didn't
get destroyed when Enterprise D went
down in Star Trek generations Betty's
pretty pissed about that turns out it's
not really that he's just in it for one
scene and it's a simulation of him it's
not the same program per se and so then
the scene's over and it ends and he's
gone I was kind of bummed out about that
he was one of the memorable characters
one of the ones that calling him a
villain doesn't really do the complexity
of the character Justice he's incredible
and he's my favorite Moriarty just ever
it was good to see him but that
Nostalgia wasn't as organic as the rest
of it in the show also the show is
really dark at a point I was like
does the Federation have a religious
thing against lights what's with the
lighting the bridge is super dank
there's at the end of the show someone's
getting their debriefing they're getting
a talking toe really dark it's just like
this one three watt bulb lighting both
of them I was like why though I get it
looks all cinematic and dramatic but at
the end when the crew gets together and
they're making their big like hey
it's we do this or the universe dies is
a bit hyperbolic Galaxy though like that
bridge is lit up just fine so I mean you
could say it's allegory like yeah it was
all depressing when they weren't
together and now light and life that
couldn't help but be like yeah but while
we're all wallowing in depression and
and the crew's not back together yet can
we have a little bit more light just a
little I almost forgot to talk about
grumpy dick Captain he was great I loved
him I'm gonna give him his proper deal
and call him Todd stashwick that is the
actor's name he is not just Dollar Store
Negan but he definitely felt like if
Negan joined Starfleet
bring that energy not that he's
bludgeoning people to death with bats or
anything but you know when they turn
Negan good were you still watching at
that point no well
I'll fill you in they turn Negan good
right but he still had that sarcastic
energy this dude is that as a captain he
was just such a grumpy chromogenous dick
I couldn't help but be entertained when
he was on screen it's one of those
characters you don't necessarily want to
go out of your way to hang out with him
but say you're hanging out with friends
and this dude showed up you'd be like oh
man it's the grumpy deck and then by the
end of the night you'd be like
but he did make me laugh he was
fantastic a total standout there's a
moment dealing with him in seven of nine
where I was like I
the move
shut up I'm not crying you're crying
track will bring on the man tears and
they're supposed to and you know when at
a point when the ax drops and it's like
okay these are the stakes and we really
gotta it's up to us crew I thought that
was actually really clever just in terms
of the tech of the Universe I really dug
that and in the last couple episodes I
didn't know who was going to live or die
I like that because it's like yeah you
bring the crew back they're all you know
aging we'll say this is the last season
of Star Trek Picard I feel like this is
probably the last time these actors are
going to reprise these roles so anything
can happen I like not knowing who's
gonna live or who's gonna die and the
stakes they were the [__] stakes and
in the end this is the final mission for
the Next Generation crew that they
deserve I mean they essentially had that
at one point with all good things it's
an incredible series finale
one of the best ever though the next
Generation movies were when it was great
it was great with first Contact ended
with a whimper in Star Trek Nemesis and
that's what we were left with that was
the last mission with this crew they
just deserved better this is that better
and I'm glad I watched it and I'm glad
it looks like the creative team listened
to fans and they're like okay they're
not digging seasons one and two oh they
want the crew to get back together and
have that whole next gen all right I
guess we'll give them that I mean in
terms of the Next Generation crew coming
back together the band is getting back
together what do you want to see
no you don't get that you don't get to
see will Reicher smash on ryzer for 10
solid episodes but you get the next best
thing your beloved crew of senior
citizens coming together going against
Starfleet protocol to save the Galaxy
yeah you get that and it's awesome all
right so Star Trek Picard season three
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
also yes I finally watched Andor